je suis arrivé dans ce monde qui est
très masculin de l'athlétisme
dominer effectivement beaucoup beaucoup
d'hommes que ce soit entraîneur
animateur ou bien
président il y avait très très peu de
présidente et au fur et à mesure il a
fallu effectivement qu'on puisse que moi
je puisse montrer pas de blanche pour
arriver au plus haut niveau parce que
c'est très très dur en tant que femme
d'arriver au plus haut niveau en tout
cas à l'époque en 2000 1999 et 2000 donc
il a fallu que je travaille plus qu'un
homme sur sur les séances d'entraînement
avec avec un entraîneur qui était plus
sévère avec une femme qu'avec un homme
suite dans le monde professionnel il a
fallu montrer encore plus
de détermination parce que quand moi
j'ai passé un mon diplôme de de et de
bébé à PT on était que deux filles pour
25 garçons donc voilà c'est c'est pas
c'est pas facile et aujourd'hui on a on
a vraiment moitié-moitié
[Musique]
on reste une société où c'est beaucoup
maman qui s'occupe des enfants
et que papa il est normal qu'il continue
le sport voilà lui garde les enfants
oui trois entraînements semaine ça lui
aimerait bien aussi faire du sport on va
dire et c'est un gros sacrifice de sa
part de ma part aussi certaines voilà
certaines femmes doivent jongler entre
leur vie personnelle leur vie de mère
leur vie de sportive
[Musique]
nous au niveau du hand déjà il y a des
disparités
entre handball masculin et Lamballe
féminin alors au niveau un pas dans
notre structure mais à haut niveau on le
voit aussi dans d'autres sports qui sont
ultra médiatisés on prend le foot les
féminines au foot qui sont pourtant
un beau palmarès elles sont pas
représentées médiatiquement on en parle
moins du sport féminin du coup on en
voit moins on envoie moins et du coup
forcément ça les enfants aujourd'hui ils
sont ultra connectés ils regardent la
télé et du coup ça donne moins envie
je travaille dans l'association femme
sport et développement donc le but de
cette association c'est de promouvoir
les valeurs du leadership féminin et de
l'olympise à travers le sport et initie
les jeunes filles de 12 à 15 ans au
volley-ball en même temps on les forme
sur le leadership elles vont faire des
sketches etc donc en fait le but de tout
ça c'est de leur donner confiance en
elle pour qu'elle puisse par exemple
lever la main au milieu du cristal c'est
vraiment pour le développement personnel
de ces jeunes filles
toutes les teintes du territoires nous
avons formé au moins près de 500 jeunes
filles et grâce à l'appui du département
de la Vienne donc c'est un grand merci
et nous espérons que ce partenariat va
perdurer dans le temps pour pouvoir
dupliquer le projet dans plusieurs
secteurs du Togo